io vengo dal futuro che voi ci credete o
no io vengo con precisione dal 16
dicembre del 2030 e credetemi per me
davvero un grandissimo onore essere qui
oggi con voi per spiegarvi o per
raccontarvi forse meglio di come
internet e le tecnologie hanno cambiato
la nostra vita nel 2030 sono passati
dodici anni da oggi
eppure ci sono numerosissimi cambiamenti
legati alle tecnologie ci sono numerose
nuove opportunità e forse alcuni rischi
non a caso ho deciso di cominciare con
l'immagine che vedete qui all'inizio di
un uomo particolarmente solo che guarda
la sua realtà
lo scopriremo mano mano che parleremo e
approfondiremo questi queste tecnologie
soprattutto il loro impatto all'interno
della vita di tutti i giorni
e credetemi in questi 12 anni uno delle
più importanti una delle più importanti
tecnologie che hanno completamente
rivoluzionato la nostra vita nel 2030 è
stato l'ingresso della realtà aumentata
ovvero di tecnologie capaci di aumentare
la nostra percezione nella vita di tutti
i giorni
io stesso in questo momento in realtà
indossa degli occhiali di realtà
aumentata e questi occhiali mi
permettono attraverso una telecamera di
riconoscervi in tempo reale
costantemente perché sono collegati al
mio profilo social e ovviamente ai
vostri profili sociali quindi anche se
voi non vedete in realtà di fronte a me
passano tutta una serie di informazioni
che arricchiscono la mia esperienza e
credetemi è stato davvero una cosa molto
molto utile per mac e soprattutto
conoscendo tante persone incontrando
tante persone in giro per il mondo
ricordi dissi ma non ricordo i nomi
automaticamente ogni volta che io guardo
ognuno di voi mi viene un suggerimento
qui sulla lente e volendo io potrei
andare ad approfondire questo genere di
informazione ea capire addirittura
quando vi ho incontrati che cosa ci
siamo detti perché questa telecamera che
voi non vedete mai al centro dei miei
occhiali registra costantemente tutto
quello che io dico tutto quello che
faccio la mia vita è ovviamente anche la
vostra vita quando vi relazionate con me
ma ovviamente la realtà aumentata che
forse torna un attimo indietro che forse
è è qualcosa che in realtà non non
riuscite fondamentalmente a comprendere
come io nel 2017 non riuscivo
effettivamente a comprendere cosa fosse
è qualcosa che tutti quanti possiamo
vedere e ricordare perché ad esempio
all'inizio del 2015 in particolar modo
furono molto pubblicizzati i cosiddetti
google plus cioè degli occhiali come
vedete con una telecamera che è appunto
approfondivano e arricchivano
l'esperienza di ciascuno
bene queste tecnologie ovviamente sono
andate avanti e oggi l'interazione
costante all'interno non solo
dell'ambiente mio personale ma anche
quello della mia casa del mio
appartamento
come vedete ho portato una fotografia
ripresa dagli occhiali di realtà
aumentata
mi permette di entrare a casa mia o
entrare ovviamente in qualsiasi
appartamento che lasci attraverso degli
oggetti intelligenti che comunicano
costantemente dei segnali
io posso controllare la temperatura casa
mia attivare i miei elettrodomestici
sapere chi c'è all'interno di casa e
questo è esattamente quello che io posso
vedere costantemente all'interno di casa
c'è di più però io posso parlare con
casa mia nel 2030 infatti all'interno di
casa mia c'è un software intelligente
ovviamente come li chiamava the voi nel
2017 che è costantemente
in ascolto per capire se ci sono delle
mie richieste specifiche
quindi o parlando all'interno di casa
automaticamente la casa fa tutto quello
che io voglio sapere o io voglio
chiedere di fare questo è ovviamente il
primo grandissimo cambiamento che c'è
stato nel 2030
in realtà che è arrivato a maturazione
nel 2030 ed è una tecnologia che ha
rivoluzionato completamente la nostra
vita nel 2030 cioè 12 anni da oggi e
tutti quanti
utilizziamo nel 2030 questo genere di
tecnologie e le utilizziamo ovviamente
non soltanto a livello personale ma
anche quando camminiamo per per la
strada
in realtà però prima di passare a dirvi
come è cambiato anche l'aspetto urbano
mi vorrei concentrare su una cosa non
proprio indifferente ed è una tecnologia
molto molto interessante che nel 2030 è
finalmente arrivata a maturazione e che
noi nel 2030 utilizziamo un po tutti
quanti mi sembra strano ma io
all'interno del mio corpo o dei
piccolissimi robot che costantemente
sono inseriti all'interno del mio flusso
sanguigno e che costantemente inviano
dati sulle mie funzioni metaboliche
sulla pressione del mio sangue sulla mia
glicemia su tutto quello che è il mio
medico che ovviamente le riceve in tempo
reale qualora io voglia può sapere o io
voglio sapere
e guardate se vi sembra qualcosa di
assolutamente irreale se vi sembra
quello che io vi sto portando oggi dal
2030 un racconto di vorrei ricordare in
realtà che nel 2009 vi ho portato un
ritaglio di giornale appositamente in
realtà questa tecnologia era stata
introdotta proprio da proprio qui in
italia proprio da un'università italiana
e ovviamente bastava arrestare in
ascolto sul cambiamento per capire dove
saremmo andati oggi quando attraverso
queste tecnologie si è arrivati appunto
a questi spider che io ho all'interno
del mio sistema sanguigno
la medicina contestualmente è arrivata
anche a creare delle cure specifiche per
il mio dna
io attraverso lo studio del mio dna da
parte ovviamente dei miei medici o
assolutamente non solo delle cure
efficaci per la mia patologia è soltanto
per la mia pagina patologia ma
attraverso questo genere di spider il
medicinale mi viene viene affidato a
questi piccolissimi micro robot
microscopici robot che io inserisco e
viene depositato esattamente nel punto
dove è più efficace
questa è la realtà della medicina nel
2030 normalmente oggi non andiamo più
dal medico per chiedere come ci sentiamo
ma normalmente il medico che fame una
domanda e mi chiede come vuoi sentirti
perché appunto lo studio del dna è
riuscito ad evolvere fino a creare
questo os x queste cure così particolari
e così mirate vi raccontavo però anche
di come la tecnologia e qui è in realtà
un immagine un po vecchia di una
tecnologia abbastanza datata per noi che
siamo nel 2030
forse arriverà nel voi nella vostra
realtà intorno al 2019 massimo 2020 ed è
proprio tramite la realtà aumentata come
vedete all'interno di questa immagine
che è costantemente all'interno anche di
una singola strada
io ricevo costantemente informazioni su
tutto quello che è di mio interesse su
dove sto andando e per esempio se io
impostarsi vocalmente con gli occhiali
di realtà aumentata per una strada
vedrei illuminarmi attraverso appunto i
miei occhiali di realtà aumentata la
strada
contestualmente al mio camminare o
andare in automobile bene in realtà come
vedete anche da questa immagine io
camminando all'interno di una strada
posso tranquillamente avere informazioni
su non soltanto ovviamente persone che
hanno il mio stesso le mie stesse
tecnologie che lascino aperta la
possibilità di essere riconosciuti e
riconoscibili camminando semplicemente
guardandovi ma anche di negozi e come
vedete anche con determinate tipologie
di rating
se un negozio può essere interessante
per i miei gusti oppure no sappiate però
che nel 2030
sta per entrare una tecnologia sta per
entrare gli usa come uso comune una
tecnologia davvero molto interessante
sempre di più le vetrine dei negozi sono
dotate di telecamere che mandano nel
2030 nelle immagini direttamente ai miei
occhiali di realtà aumentata con una
pubblicità assolutamente mirata sul me
stesso perché ovviamente i miei occhiali
costantemente registrando tutta la mia
vita
sanno perfettamente che cosa ho comprato
io ho incontrato dove sono andato a
mangiare e di conseguenza io sono ultra
prof ultra profilato quindi tutti qua
tutti le informazioni che io ho relative
a ho accumulato durante la giornata
durante i miei mesi e che un relativi
alla mia vita vengono immagazzinate e le
vetrine e mandano direttamente una
pubblicità con la mia immagine con
qualcosa che mi vogliono ovviamente
vendere e dicendomi che se ho visto la
pubblicità sui miei occhiali di realtà
aumentata entrando adesso ho un
fortissimo sconto è in realtà anche
questo è qualcosa che vuoi nel 2017
avreste dovuto già sapere perché come
leggete ancora una volta da questo
ritaglio di giornale che io ho preso dal
passato nel 2013 già c'erano delle
startup che lavoravano proprio per fare
questo cioè per monetizzare i dati
personali mi ricordo perfettamente 12
anni fa come era facile per noi regalare
i nostri dati personali all'interno dei
social network è però particolarmente
anche soddisfacente sotto determinati
punti di vista
benissimo nel 2030 in realtà vi do un
ottima notizia
queste cose non le fa più nessuno sapete
perché perché io posso pagare al
supermercato cedendo i miei dati
personali dai miei occhiali di realtà
aumentata e acquistare dei beni di
servizio di uso comune
semplificando io posso tranquillamente
decidere se pagare con gli euro pagare
con qualsiasi altra tipologia di moneta
alternativa oppure pagare cedendo i miei
dati personali
ovviamente al supermercato in parte che
venga in quel genere di prodotti
e anche a chi li ha prodotti scusate il
gioco di parole quelle cose che io sto
comprando e quindi nessuno più mette i
dati i suoi dati personali gratuitamente
all'interno dei social network questa è
stata una rivoluzione molto molto
importante soprattutto perché strada
facendo
dal 2017 2018 al 2030 il concetto di
privacy e di protezione dei dati
personali come potete immaginare è
andato via via scomparendo
perché in una società ultra regis ultra
connessa perché ormai non ci connettiamo
più a internet internet è costantemente
all'interno della nostra vita perché
ovviamente imi occhiali realtà aumentata
sono costantemente connessi alla rete
internet non aveva più senso parlare di
protezione dei dati personali e di
privacy nel momento in cui io
costantemente registro la faccia di una
persona registro la sua voce registro
alla sua reazione anche minimi minica
facciale quando incontra quando ci
stiamo per salutare e questi potrebbero
aprire degli scenari che però ci
porterebbero un po troppo lontano
e allora ovviamente la privacy è stato
la privacy e la protezione dei dati è
stato un diritto che si è andato via via
diluendo fino a che è appunto questo
genere di tecnologia e non ha portato
alla possibilità di pagare con i dati
personali
e allora è ritornato nel 2030 come un
diritto davvero percepito come valore
soprattutto dei giovani molto molto
elevato ovviamente tutto intorno a me
nel 2030 è connesso a internet
girando per le strade costantemente gli
oggetti richiamate nel 2017 internet of
things di internet degli oggetti sono
dappertutto nel mio 2030 sono
dappertutto e costantemente ricevono e
mandano dati a me stesso
domandano informazioni come avete visto
dalla fotografia che abbiamo fatto
vedere prima mandano anche informazioni
relative allo stato del traffico al a
quanta gente affolla determinati negozi
e la salubrità dell'aria e così via
tutto è interconnesso
adesso nel 2000 nel 2030 anche le
macchine e questo ancora una volta è
qualcosa di cui sicuramente ne avete
sentito già parlare nel 2017
le macchine sono autonome
vi posso confermare che nel 2030 lo sono
anche se non sono completamente autonome
la persona all'interno della macchina
ancora una grandissima responsabilità
soprattutto legale in sulla questione
degli incidenti è un caso di
malaguratamente che qualcosa vada vada
storto quindi sono autonome sono ibride
ibrida mente autonome le chiamiamo nel
2030 perché appunto le problematiche
legali su di chi sia la responsabilità
in caso di un incidente non sono ancora
state risolte ma sicuramente le macchine
oggi sono dei veri e propri enormi
computer che viaggiano che viaggiano per
le strade e permettono a noi di
distrarci molto di più che nel 2017
tutto questo ha portato a un cambiamento
anche di internet internet non è più la
rete come voi oggi la conoscete è nato
da un po di anni a questa parte la
cosiddetta internet delle emozioni in
realtà oggi attraverso appunto queste
tecnologie che vi ho raccontato molto
brevemente lo ammetto e soprattutto la
grande capacità di collezione di questi
dati è chiaro che si può arrivare a
profilare un soggetto e quindi a
conoscere un soggetto fin dentro le sue
emozioni non più soltanto sui gusti o su
quello che ha comprato oppure su quello
che desidera fare si riesce alcune
società riescono ad arrivare a profilare
addirittura alle emozioni non fosse
altro perché appunto costantemente
giriamo con delle telecamere attaccate
ai nostri ai nostri occhiali e oggi il
mondo è degli algoritmi in particolar
modo degli algoritmi di intelligenza
artificiale che raccolgono questa mole
enorme di dati la categorizzano e ne
estraggono valore più velocemente
possibile
oggi i veri ricchi del mondo sono quelli
che hanno comprato oppure che hanno
sviluppato gli algoritmi di intelligenza
artificiale più veloci e più performanti
e allora
ritorno alla mia immagine iniziale e
ritorno soprattutto al tema che ci
propone oggi questa teteks l'uomo resta
al centro internet ci aveva promesso di
interconnettersi tutti quanti di creare
un'enorme rete
in realtà vi posso dire che nel mio 2030
l'uomo è molto solo è chiuso all'interno
di una gabbia di realtà creata da
internet stessa che lo protegge e lo
mantiene vivo all'interno delle sue
inter relazioni sociali economiche
lavorative e questo è un grandissimo
problema per noi del 2030 ve lo posso
assicurare
e quindi il mio augurio è che oggi si
apra gli occhi non verso delle barriere
verso il futuro
ma verso un approccio al futuro che sia
davvero consapevole dei rischi ma
ovviamente anche delle enormi
opportunità e quindi il mio viaggio nel
tempo di oggi porta fondamentalmente un
messaggio molto molto importante
ricordiamoci che per quanto la
tecnologia possa aiutare e facilitare
determinate tipologie di attività è
sempre più come vi ho raccontato lo
faremo nel 2030 l'uomo deve rimanere
sempre al centro del mondo soprattutto
nelle sue interazioni umane con gli
altri
io vi ringrazio e che dire di aspetto
nel vostro futuro
[Applauso]
[Musica]